so I know you go after projects that
terrify you is Barbie the most
terrifying project you've done thus far
no he's easily easily easily so
terrifying is so what is number two oh
um well I mean honestly whatever project
I'm working on feels like the most
terrifying one but yeah it feels like
the God I mean
they're all terrifying but yeah Barbie
right now yeah it was this is totally
terrifying the whole time yeah is there
a single scene or aspect of this movie
that you were most nervous about you
know executing the way that you wanted I
this movie was made was a giant question
mark it was like I don't know how we're
going to do all of this because I didn't
I you know I wanted to do practical
builds for everything I also wanted to
use always anytime I could use whatever
film technique from like 1959 was so I
needed to build the entire thing by a
miniature and then shoot the miniature
and then composite that into the image
like I had to do everything practically
like the entire Transportation sequences
that's all practical
builds that's all happens in camera and
so everything had to be worked out it
was like um
it would I spoke with Rodrigo Prieto
Sarah Greenwood and Jacqueline Duran who
were DP uh set designer costume designer
I talked to them for a year before we
were even in like Prep Prep because it
we we just didn't know how any of it was
possible I mean it was it it was
it the whole thing was extremely this
sort of um every day was like this this
challenge of like execution but it was
you know in a way because I had this
very clear Vision that I wanted
everything to be
practical and in camera it made it easy
in terms of how we went about stuff like
with you know the mermaids or something
it's like well if you were making a
stage show she'd be on a sort of almost
like a seesaw rig like you wouldn't have
like a big
jump up into the air and a tail flip in
a splash you would just rigger up and
rig her down and and it was like well
sort of walking into that Simplicity was
was part of it so
all of that be I mean it was it was just
a I I mean the the the the set designers
and the figuring out all the houses and
everything it was just a it was it was
an execution
done so perfectly I am so grateful to
everyone who made it with everything you
accomplished on this yeah going forward
have you like I guess acquired a new
filmmaking goal or maybe does like one
of your goals feel more Within Reach
because this movie exists yes yes uh yes
I mean right now
um every time I've gone to make a film
there's always you know there's always
something challenging or new aspect to
it and and this one it felt like I got
um
it was like a level up it was like a and
and also just learning how um how how to
how to execute something like this how
to how to work with certain constraints
how to realize the best way to realize
certain Visions like all of that you
know I'm everybody I think who's a
director has a bit of a fantasy baseball
team in their head of like the movies
they're gonna make in the future and I
have movies I want to make that are you
know tiny and I have movies I want to
make that are huge but I knew that if I
wanted to make some of these big canvas
movies I had to
you gotta get the hours under your belt
because you can't it I mean they can be
totally overwhelming so
um it it definitely makes me feel like
okay now I feel slightly more prepared
to maybe tackle than the next thing but
yeah it's um you know it's uh
it's only new mistakes only new new
challenges it's just um I'm just so
lucky that I get to do it